Hilary Clinton recently condemned the
policies we've been talking about as
horrific that would surely come as news
to the Hillary Clinton of just 15 years
ago in 2003 this is what Hillary Clinton
said about the crisis on the border
watch this I am you know again illegal
immigrants certainly we've got to do
more at our borders and people have to
stop employing illegal immigrants huh
nothing has changed since then of course
except for her party's calculation that
it could only win by importing a new
class of voters which they are trying
their best to do mark Stein is an author
and a columnist and he joins us tonight
mark I don't know if you were prepared
really to take a lecture on the Bible
from Hillary Clinton and Barbara Boxer
and the rest but do you feel edified as
a Christian and an American by the the
new theocrats on the left it's
interesting I think they're being rather
selective in their southern biblical
fervor
it's very important to the left to
maintain this particular public policy
which is what it was as you said at the
top of the show that's what immigration
is it's a public policy yet whenever
it's treated as such Hillary and the
rest of the left and I regret now an
entire phalanx of first ladies has
decided that we have to have the
sentimental ization of public policy
well which is it this is a country that
is supposedly on orange alert over half
of the illegal aliens present broke into
a country on orange alert that is to say
they've come here since 9/11 Americans
shuffle like a bovine herd through
security that demands to know that the
consistency of their pumpkin pie if
they're flying home to Thanksgiving from
New York to Cleveland but the rest of
the world is entitled to walk across the
Rio Grande if they happen to have a
little moppet in tow with them you can't
have it both ways right now Americans
are living on orange alert if they make
a domestic flight but their borders are
open you're the chumps of the planet for
going along with it and I
and I may be the harshest person here as
speaking tonight because I know as a
legal immigrant how heartless and
ruthless the legal immigration
bureaucracy in this country can be to
children and the separation of families
and all that and these Democrats and
Laura Bush never has a word to say about
that what would happen if you showed up
at the airport without a driver's
license and said look I have a moral
right to get on this plane and you're a
racist for not letting me on would that
work no no it wouldn't I mean we're
bifurcating into a into a society where
the law-abiding are subject to ever more
onerous constraints while the avowedly
lawless are somehow venerated and
fetishized i will say as illegal that
you've lived this if i could just pause
and say you're i mean you actually are
foreign-born and you have without
getting too personal but you have a
family i mean how has the immigration
system treated your family well i'll
tell you i was crossing at Derby line
from on one time I won't go into all the
details but the rather officious twerp
at the border threatened to call ice and
have my daughter deported and he said
then she'd be in Canada and you'd be
stuck here in America and I said I
wouldn't be much of a father if I did
that because I'll tell you ten minutes
after you deport her I'll be back in
whatever country you deport her to
because if the price of being in America
is that I have to be separated from my
children then I pass and I am surprised
frankly we're told these are just
hard-working people are being snatched
from the bosoms of their mothers it's
awful it's heartbreaking why don't we
just say at the border
well you can't come in but if you do
your children will be taken from you and
why don't these people then say oh well
I don't want to be separated from my
children can I go back across the Rio
Grande to the southern shore this is the
difference in cement between the lawful
and the lawless I can promise you're the
only person on television to tell us ask
that question I'm glad that
did Mark Steyn thank you thanks a lot
Tucker